[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be doing some
ranking based on the performance of
previous ranking style videos you guys
at least most of you seem to enjoy them
so here's another at this stage i've
ranked a lot of different types of
characters i've ranked the most powerful
slytherins gryffindors hufflepuffs
ravenclaws auras death eaters
dumbledore's army members order of the
phoenix members and more but what i
haven't done yet is rank the most
powerful pure blood wizards in the
wizarding world blood status is one of
the most controversial aspects of the
wizarding world a concept in which
wizarding families can be distinguished
by the level of magically endowed family
members generally speaking people are
slotted into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood or
muggle we're introduced to quite a few
characters in the harry potter story
that come from these pure bloodlines and
they certainly aren't afraid to remind
us of it
malfoy's however what we must remember
is that at the end of the day pure blood
status doesn't mean anything the most
powerful pure bloods are not the most
powerful wizards in fact a top 10 list
for the most powerful wizards would only
include a couple of the people in this
list the majority of powerful witches
and wizards in the wizarding world are
actually half bloods before we get
started i want to mention a couple of
things first of all i'm going to omit
the hogwarts founders and the perils as
they're sort of op
second of all i'm going to try my best
to only include one person from each
wizarding family as otherwise the list
could get quite overcrowded with one
surname thirdly i want you to pause the
video and comment your top 10 list down
below before you dive in anyway without
further ado here is my top 10 list of
the most powerful pureblood wizards in
the wizarding world if i miss or forget
a name that is deserving of a spot
please forgive me number 10 bill weasley
bill weasley was the eldest weasley
child born as early as 1970 he attended
hogwarts between 1982 and 1989 and
during this time he became both a
prefect and head boy bill is considered
by many to be the most powerful of the
weasley children largely due to his
occupation as a curse breaker one who
removes counters or breaks curses placed
on objects the profession is thought to
be extremely challenging and
particularly dangerous requiring a
complex understanding of magic and a
proven ability to perform a broad
spectrum of different spells bill was
highly skilled in arithmancy dueling
transfiguration conjuration charms spell
creation divination and even the dark
arts bill was truly a powerful wizard
before you say hey molly was the
strongest weasley watch the video a
little longer 9. frank longbottom frank
longbottom doesn't make it into the
story much that's because he's
tragically incapacitated during the
first wizarding war you see frank and
his wife alice longbottom the parents of
neville longbottom were both powerful
auras that joined the order of the
phoenix and opposed lord voldemort
unfortunately for them however they were
a little too good at their jobs defying
him on three occasions as well as
capturing and imprisoning many of
voldemort's death eaters because of this
they were honed in on and targeted one
day frank and alice were attacked with
the cruciatus curse by bellatrix barty
crouch jr and rodolfos lestrange though
the pair didn't die they were unable to
continue normal life and effectively
went insane frank being targeted tells
me that he was a very valuable asset for
the order and likely a very powerful
wizard who deserves a spot on this list
8. james potter james potter was a
british purebred wizard born march 27
1960 to parents fleemont and euphemia
potter like the other marauders james
was so skilled in the subject of
transfiguration that he was able to
become an animagus the staggeringly
young age of 15. after successfully
achieving this notable accomplishment he
was able to transform into a stag
whenever he wanted in order to
accomplish such a feat it was also
necessary that james have sufficient
knowledge of potion making as becoming
an animagus for the first time requires
an animagus potion a highly complicated
potion that requires exceptional potion
making ability in addition to
transfiguration and potion making james
was also a talented duelist having
defeated snape on numerous occasions and
an accomplished practitioner of charms
having helped to create the marauders
map alongside the other members of the
group 7. sirius black sirius black the
godfather of harry potter and member of
the black family began studying at
hogwarts in the year 1971 along with the
other marauders during his time at
school he was talented the rebellious
young man with a knack for performing
magic while sirius's magical development
was somewhat stunted by the extensive
amount of time that he spent in azkaban
he still ended up being a supremely
powerful wizard in addition to being
highly skilled at transfiguration and
eventually becoming an animagus assuming
the form of a black dog cirrus was also
skilled at jewelling brewing potions
producing charms producing non-verbal
magic and even occlumency 6. molly
pruitt weasley next up we have molly
pruitt or as most of you know her ollie
weasley that's right molly hailed from
the powerful pureblood wizarding family
the pruitt's the pruitt family produced
many powerful witches and wizards
including molly's brothers gideon and
fabian who died in the first wizarding
war while fighting off five at death
eaters molly's other most significant
achievement was besting powerful witch
bellatrix the strange one of the most
powerful witches in the entire wizarding
world and one of lord voldemort's most
loyal followers she was primarily
portrayed as an unassuming motherly
figure known for her caring and
nurturing manner however during the
battle of hogwarts molly proved that in
times of adversity she's able to tap
into levels of power that will give even
the most powerful witches and wizards a
run for their money she was skilled in
jewelling charms healing magic potions
transfiguration and even the dark arts
5. hora slughorn professor horus loghorn
was a british wizard that worked at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry he was a highly respected and
accomplished man who served as both
potions master and head of slytherin
house he was a brilliant man and perhaps
one of the most talented potioneers of
his time slughorn was a triple threat he
was cunning wise and book smart which
made him an exceptionally powerful man
in fact when the death eaters were
returning they tried it time and time
again to recruit slurkhorn who was
rather modest about his own capabilities
what would the death eaters want for the
poor broken down old buffer like me i
imagine that they would want to turn
your considerable talents to coercion
torture and murder as well as being a
master potioneer slughorn was also a
very talented duelist transfiguration
expert oklahomans charms expert dark
arts practitioner and as it turns out
expert piano player 4. kingsley
shacklebolt kingsley shacklebolt was a
british pureblood wizard order of the
phoenix member powerful aura and later
minister for magic in his youth
shacklebolt attended hogwarts and
performed particularly well on his nudes
fulfilling all the necessary
qualifications to become an aura before
eventually becoming minister for magic
kingsley was a high-ranking aura despite
a very powerful and balanced arsenal of
magical capabilities shacklebolt's
fellow order members held him in a very
high regard and even lord voldemort
himself considered kingsy to be a
powerful wizard if that isn't an
indicator of his level of power then i
don't know what is
3. alistair moody considered by many to
be the most famous aura of all time
alistair moody was a very impressive
wizard moody joined the order during the
first wizarding war and is said to be
personally responsible for a very large
portion of the witches and wizards in
azkaban this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
community moody was a truly impressive
dark wizard catcher and warrior he would
do whatever it took to win and moody
served with great distinction during the
first wizarding war even losing an eye
leg and nose in battles against the
death eaters moody was incredibly brave
but also extremely powerful particularly
in his prime he was a master of dark
arts defense against the dark arts
jewelling charms transfiguration potions
herbology apparition flying non-verbal
magic and even occlumency 2. barty
crouch jr barty crouch jr was a british
pureblood wizard and the son of ministry
of magic official martinez crouch senior
crouch jr has a rich history with the
death eaters and joined them in his
teenage years barty crouch jr famously
kidnaps and prisons the powerful
madaimudi then teaches at hogwarts
school for an entire year in his stead
what's so impressive about this that he
was completely undetected even by the
powerful dumbledore crouch was powerful
in every area of magic and was known to
be skilled at dueling potions charms
transfiguration occlumency nonverbal
magic and more but what made crouch
truly dangerous was his intelligence
achieving 12 owls during his time at
hogwarts i think the crouch may be one
of the most underrated wizards in all of
history
number one bellatrix black lestrange
bellatrix lestrange born bellatrix black
from the house of black was a
frightening pure blood witch that came
from a long line of powerful witches and
wizards with a twisted agenda bellatrix
is undeniably one of the most powerful
people in the wizarding world
basically only comes after dumbledore
voldemort grindelwald and maybe snape
when it comes to raw power bellatrix was
a known proponent of the cruciatus curse
and had considerable knowledge in the
realm of the dark arts she was also an
expert duelist charms expert powerful
oklahomans and tenacious warrior yes
bellatrix was defeated by molly weasley
but i think it's safe to say that she
just let her ego get the better of her
if she hadn't underestimated molly she
may still be around today and that
concludes this list how did my top 10
match up against yours did i mess up and
miss any obvious ones that deserved a
spot comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]